housing is in crisis thousands
demonstrated against the failure of
successive governments to build enough
homes housing is such a massive issue
housing is what kind of brings you
secure it brings you stability it kind
of allows you to then progressing your
further life if you don't have a hull
she can't on the future reggae artist
Apache Indian wants to be the voice of
the disenfranchised generation the
generation that can't even afford homes
and feels no one is doing anything about
it you're probably getting the proper
glider the trying to raise money for
their deposits for the house it's very
very difficult for them and it's causing
problems within the families the housing
market may be vibrant but young people
are still priced out for a first time
buyer is the struggle this is your
master katy has had to borrow money from
family and friends to raise enough for
deposits this really said feel that the
fact that not everyone can buy their own
property it's it's frustrating it's left
a whole generation wondering how
something as basic as finding a home has
become so difficult recent figures from
the housing federation show that to
raise money for deposit fourteen percent
of 18 to 34 year olds are considering
living with parents one in ten are
thinking of taking a second job fifteen
percent are considering delaying having
a family or getting married and one in
twenty five are even thinking of taking
part in paid medical trials the figure
suggests we need around two hundred and
forty five thousand new homes a year
just to keep up with current demand
instead we're building around half that
the lowest level since nineteen twenty
some people think it's because young
people who are most affected don't vote
but it's not become a political priority
today campaigners set up an inflatable
house to draw attention to the issue
they say the tide is turning people are
recognizing their needs houses built in
their local area for their children to
live in and that's why we need all
political parties to commit to ending
the housing crisis within a generation
the three main parties have all promised
to build more affordable homes in the
future but none at the necessary rate to
meet current needs it's no surprise
campaigners say that so many first-time
buyers have been left feeling stuck fo
Hirsch Sky News